well many people ask me about the
virtues of psychedelics was I've written
about this on my blog and and in my book
waking up and they were at a point my
early in my in my inquiry they were
indispensable and this is this is an
experience that's shared by many
Westerners it's hard to really recommend
psychedelics without serious caveats
because they some of them I think are
probably neurotoxic some are really well
tolerated but but still you can have
very scary destabilize and experiences
on them and so you just can't without
caveat recommend that people drop acid
or take MDMA so it's it's everything I
say on the subject should be understood
in that context but for some people
taking a drug is the only way they're
gonna notice that it's possible to have
a very different experience of the world
they they're sufficiently lumpin and
unincluded
if you tell them to meditate if you tell
them you teach them mindfulness you tell
them how to follow their breath they
will look inside for 30 seconds or 30
minutes and see nothing of interest and
walk away feeling that there's no there
there either doesn't work for them or
that everyone else must be just faking
it or that there's it requires a certain
talent and a certain degree of luck
therefore to to have enough
concentration to connect with any quote
spiritual practice the first time or
even the tenth time or even after a year
of attempting it because it's just these
practices are difficult and and the the
conditioning of our minds to just
ceaselessly talk is deep so as Terence
Mckenna once said psychedelics are the
only method that truly guarantee in
effect and this effect can be again very
painful he's not just not you're not
necessarily gonna have a good experience
but there's no question that if someone
gives you a hundred micrograms of acid
something is going to happen you know
two hours later
the significance of your existence will
have just been borne down on you like an
avalanche and and again this can be
terrifying or it can be absolutely
sublime depending on various causes and
conditions but the one thing it cannot
be is boring and that that is you can't
say that about yoga or meditation or
just going into solitude or any anything
else that any other non-pharmacological
means of inquiry so where drugs have
been indispensable for many people is in
advertising the possibility of a change
in consciousness and so I don't think
they're they're durable methods for
people that you I don't think you you
need or should just keep taking drugs
month after month year after year as as
a as a mode of spiritual inquiry but
there's certainly a period in in many
people's lives at the beginning where
you wouldn't have you wouldn't even see
a glimmer of reason to to suspect that's
that a radical change and the nature of
your experience would be possible my
first experience with psychedelics that
was was important that actually shifted
my view of human possibility was with am
MDMA which I took before it became a
club drug I think this was in 1987 I
took it and and no one I knew no one of
my generation had taken it and although
the drug obviously goes back many
decades before that and it had not been
adopted by popular culture as a party
drug so this was it was coming very much
out of a therapeutic community people
were doing in a closeted way
psychotherapy with it and I took it as a
means of discovering something about the
nature of my mind it was not a social
situation I was just a friend and I were
alone and we took it together and just
had a conversation on this drug and what
was revelatory about it was that it was
it was an experience of absolute
sobriety it was not there was
there's no druggie component to it we
just became clearer and clearer and
clearer in our thinking and and feeling
and the the crucial component of this
was a loss of any feeling of self
concern I was no longer looking at
myself through my friends eyes I was no
longer worried about what he was
thinking about me I was no longer subtly
correcting course based on changes I saw
in how he was perceiving what I was
saying there was a whole veneer of fear
frankly that that I didn't know was
there that got stripped away and it was
just just just got a naked awareness of
the present moment and what came into
that void was a very clear understanding
that I loved him that I that I and I
here I was 18 or 19 and I was not in the
habit of you know thinking about how
much I loved the men in my life and
here's one of my best friends and I just
realized would they you know it sounds
absolutely pedestrian to say it but but
but I realized that I wanted him to be
happy in a way that I that was just it
was like a you know lightning bolt and
and the what was truly revolutionary
about this insight was that so I'm the
feeling that came crashing down to that
point was just you know boundless love
for one of my best friends and
absolutely no egoic self concerned no
possibility for feeling Envy for feeling
any kind of petty emotion that separated
myself from him but then I realized in
the next moment that I would feel this
way for anyone who walked through the
door that there was nothing contingent
on our relationship about this feeling
that was not it was not a it was not
justified by my friendship with him this
was the way I felt for every other
conscious being so this is the way I
would feel for the postman if he walked
through the door and that that suddenly
opened my mind to the possibility of
being like Jesus whoever he was you know
that these icons of traditional religion
were not all epileptics and
schizophrenic sand and frauds these were
people who and again we can be skeptical
about any specific individual you know
some of them could have been
schizophrenic some of them could have
had temporal lobe epilepsy but some
people historically and even in the
present have borne witness to this
experience where you can you can you can
just quite literally lose your self
concern in a way that makes you love
people unconditionally and so you know
that was the experience I had on MDMA it
you know frankly blew my mind and it
took me years for me to integrate this
understanding of this possibility into
my intellectual life and it it prompted
me to to seek to have this experience in
other ways if you know for many many
years I spent years studying meditation
and in various contexts mostly in India
and Nepal and you know I can say you can
have this experience without MDMA this
is it's not MDA MDMA isn't the only way
to have it and the truth is virtually
any experience you can have with
psychedelics you can have without
psychedelics because all psychedelics do
is modulate the existing neuro chemistry
of the brain they're not doing something
that the brain can't do on its own
either you're just playing with
neurotransmitters or mimicking
neurotransmitters I have had the same
experience to to more or less similar
degree just through meditation but I
it's clear to me that I would never have
suspected that such an experience was
possible but for my experimenting with
MDMA in the beginning and so I have to
just acknowledge that again issuing the
caveat that that this drug could be
could well be bad for you there's some
evidence of his neurotoxicity and
there's also a lot of evidence that that
research has been heavily politicized so
it's you have to be cautious on both
sides but I can't advocate that we drop
MDMA in the water supply and and cure us
of our egocentricity it's you know
there's reasons to be circumspect
you